We've already seen Indians of North America.
Now suppose we have a look at what happened
some 1,500 kilometers south of the present day Mexican border.
The sombreros around Mexico City, eh?
Well, the year is 1486.
We're in Aztec country.
Now, they have the same monuments, the same pyramids,
same lifestyle as their cousins farther north.
But their social order, their society, that's different.
Now, here we are probably some 20,000 years after the first tribes crossed the Bering Straits from Siberia, and, well, they ended up here.
They'll have some good things, eh?
Yeah, they'll have skins, cloth feathers, not to mention jewels.
So what do we do? What do we do? What do we do?
Now, don't get excited. Now, give them time to get here.
Calm down. Don't move. I'll give you a signal.
This is some profession.
Some profession.
Great honor for us to receive dignitary from Mexico City. How about a little pulque to honor visit?
Uh, we didn't come to drink. We're on business, and we don't drink and drive.
Since you put it that way, no pulque can we do for you.
Our merchants are endlessly attacked and robbed near your city.
What?
We don't like it. We don't like it at all.
Therefore, you will hereafter be under the protection of our grand and venerated emperor,
and you will submit to all our laws.
Yes, all first. Just what are these laws of your...
No, nothing too harsh.
For a start, you send to Mexico City a splendid gift in gold,
but, like an effort, a nice gift in jewels, feathers, coats...
What?
Well, you know the sort of thing.
In addition, the prize spot in your temple is reserved exclusively for our sun god, Vici de Polchi.
At least you know what you want. And was there anything else?
You might throw in one or two magnificent young slaves, boys and girls. I'd say that about covers it.
I see. Give me time to think it over.
You do that, but think it over fast.
Meanwhile, I bought you some trinkets, just in case you need them.
Shields and spears.
At Tenochtitlan, Mexico, the superb Aztec capital.
One 20-day month has gone by, and their chief still hasn't given in.
Now it's time to go and warn the Texcocos.
And I suppose you won't drink our pulque either.
I suppose, well, what is it? Why'd you come?
Our friends in Mexico City have been waiting for a month, and they're angry.
We're allies with the Texcoco. We can still arrange things.
Otherwise, in strict conformity with the law, we will have to break your neck, and it'd be a shame.
Gifts, nice shields, nice spears, hmm?
To arm your warriors, hmm?
And also, a small quantity of our sacred oil.
With this, you can resist any attack by any army.
Since you're a noble and courageous man, chief,
I'll give you another 20 days to give in.
20 suns and moons, and still there's no answer.
The Clacopans have to be warned.
Your wise elders wouldn't listen to the Mexico men or the Texcocos.
That's why we, the allies of the Clacopans,
decided to speak directly with you, warriors,
who have to come out now and help our troops.
Now, you will agree to this, or we'll devastate your villages
and take all of you as slaves.
The same, we brought you gifts.
You have another 20 days to think it over, but this is your last chance.
After that, it'll be too late.
We're right into the trap set for the Mexicans.
Confirmed victory for the Mexico men.
In the city, and there are over us.
Beautiful. Is that where they're going to sacrifice us?
Yes, I'm afraid so.
Oh, that will be a great honor for us, venerated father.
Father's in school.
A great priest here among us today.
Listen with great respect.
You are my children.
Today I will speak of our great god, warrior of the sun, Huitzilopochtli.
Our world is coming to an end, for the sun has nearly completed its course.
The sun must receive new energy every day if it is to reappear.
This source of energy, it is precious water.
That is human blood.
That is why we must take prisoners to satisfy our sun god.
The sun comes back at dawn only if we make sacrifices, so we must take prisoners.
Yes, and to take prisoners, we need warriors.
To be a warrior, what a calling.
Yes, I recall only too well when I was a young warrior.
Yes, yes.
In my path, give you a strong body and an iron will,
forge a sterling character and a spirit of public service.
All this is the purpose of your education.
And you girls, you may aspire to the coveted title of priestess,
or you can marry if you so desire.
But you boys, at the age of ten, your hair is cut,
leaving only a hank.
That bit will be cut.
The day you bring in your first live prisoner,
you can even group into twos and threes.
Yeah, no, that's allowed.
Three battles, and if you haven't brought in any prisoners,
then you are demoted.
Yes, and you have to return to civilian life.
On the other hand, suppose you take or kill four enemy warriors,
then you're promoted to superior grade,
and you're chiefs, knights of the jaguar, knights of the eagle,
honored by the emperor?
How will our honored and most gallant warriors come?
Who dies in combat?
Or, upon the sacrificial stone, becomes a companion of the sun
and takes his place in the brilliant aura around that star.
For life and death are just two forms of the same reality.
Our warriors guarantee our liberty.
It is their valor and courage that have built our empire, but you know that.
You don't really know all that much about it.
Could you tell us some more about it?
Yes, tell us. Tell us the old...
Since you ask.
Yes, it was some 15,000 years ago our ancestors hunted mammoths.
Yes, but then they settled down and started planting crops.
And they created ceramic objects, built temples, tumulus for their gods.
They were very talented, wouldn't you say?
They invented a talent, writing, arts of all kinds.
And then the Mexicas, a small tribe, they would hunt.
And they'd keep on the move.
They had a very great priest, an ancient relative of mine, and a great god, Huitzilopochtli.
And one day...
Soon you'll see eagle perched on cactus, devouring snake.
There you will build my temple and city for the people.
I don't think I quite understand it.
He's a snake devouring a cactus.
There's an eagle sitting on a snake.
Messages from gods can be very inscrutable.
Over there, do you see what I see?
An eagle on a cactus, and he's devouring a snake.
It's here.
On this spot, we will construct our own city.
We're here and nowhere else.
The gods have so told us.
Now all of you get to work.
Work!
Otherwise, the sky will fall on our heads and the sun will stand still in the sky.
Of course, in time, there were wars and treachery, murders, an ordinary run of history.
But a wise prince, Itzhakotl, created a confederation with the people of Texcoco and Tlacopan.
Today, our city is the most beautiful in the whole world, and tomorrow, tomorrow, we will consecrate our great temple.
Priestess had enough for today.
That's enough.
The gods have had their share.
You were a brave chief in war.
Would you be free?
We will give you an army to command, and we'll all respect you.
Why do you insult your son, venerated father?
Have I not earned an honorable death?
Go on, tell your priest to make one last effort.
What do you say we fly a little?
Right, that is a very good idea.
Who else here would like to go flying with us?
Me!
It was cream in a thing.
A little too much pull came.
Not at all.
No, I assure you, officer, we just went for a little spin.
The word of honor.
Smell your breath.
Not bad. No trace of alcohol. This time you were lucky. As you know, drunken driving here is punishable by death.
You've been warned. Good day.
What that fellow should use is a breathalyzer. It's a real shame it hasn't been invented yet.
Now tell you some of the laws and regulations that we're all expected to obey.
Now that it's come up, why not start with laws on drunkenness?
It's not allowed, except for very old people. It's like a destructive whirlpool.
It would destroy all that is good in our city.
All manner of evil doing springs from it.
Crimes and all sorts of traffic accidents and misdemeanors.
That's why any man caught in a drunken state.
If he's a commoner, he's roundly beaten and his head is shaved.
If a nobleman, he's hanged in public.
Fate awaits anyone who's caught using peyotl.
There are other drugs that make you see and hear things that aren't there.
Another sort of drunkenness, but just as harmful.
Stealing? If committed by an ordinary commoner, here be made a slave for a period of time.
If committed by a nobleman, it means death.
Cheating? Or changing the boundaries of your property to the detriment of others, death.
Crime of adultery. The two guilty parties will have their heads crushed.
Homosexuality? It depends on the sex of the couple. For women, it is death. For men, well, nobody's perfect.
Oh, yes. A few pertinent remarks concerning slavery.
The slave will be respected and cannot be resold unless three masters complain about him.
And if he escapes and manages to reach the emperor's palace, he is free.
Oh, yes. I nearly forgot a rather important detail.
Anyone committing a crime has the right to confess once and that one time he or she will not be punished for that crime.
It's almost half of our corn harvest he's claiming is a legal tax.
Sure, but, oh, that's nothing, friend.
You're forgotten? During the harvest, we had to take time off so we could work on the dikes.
Yeah, to build the temple of Zoccipoli, the god of summer. But no, that's nothing.
And all the hours we spent on the second aqueduct.
To have more turkeys to give to the emperor. But that's nothing, friend.
What do you mean, nothing? You're kidding.
Sure, don't you remember what happened to me two years ago?
I harvested 40 baskets of corn, and the tax collector said I had to give him 20 of them.
Well, 20 basketfuls.
Well, I have to save four of them for seed corn.
For my next crop.
And what do you think he said, Dan?
Hold on.
I was forgetting.
There's an increase in taxation this year.
You owe me a dozen more.
How do you expect me to feed my family, all my children?
I'll hardly have enough corn for tortillas.
And he says...
Use red beans and black.
In tortillas?
Yeah.
Do you happen to have red beans?
Well, sure, I have about seven or eight sacks back there.
You know what he had the nerve to say?
No, at this point, I couldn't guess.
He just smiled and said...
It's luck that you mentioned it.
Tax on red beans, too.
That'll be four socks.
So I had no choice.
I gave him those two, but he still wasn't satisfied.
Know what he did then?
No, the mind boggles.
Go on.
He asked me if I had any black ants.
Honest, he asked me if I had black ants.
Incredible, then.
So what did you say?
If you want to know, we're infested with black ants.
And they're causing me all kinds of trouble.
Be generous.
You keep your ants.
Then he packed himself up and was off like lightning.
Disappeared in no time at all.
Could have been worse.
Oh, worse.
Could have happened to me.
It can't be much further. We'll be there soon.
Yes, you're right. Once we're there, we'll have to bring the cloth we have to give in exchange.
Not merchants.
Okay, Chief, but they could be rich peasants.
And a good harvest, Chief. We don't mind grabbing that, Chief.
We don't mind at all. It takes a lot less work than growing the stuff in the hot sun.
At my signal.
And General Chief, his head's over there.
What?
Who's your future daughter-in-law?
Parents arrange things with the marriage brokers.
You see, our son is strong and brave.
Yes, so he appears. Quite a good catch.
In any case, she's still too young to think.
No return tomorrow, and we'll discuss it again.
She's ugly, good for nothing, but if you insist, we'll consider the question.
People, I'm here to ask for your daughter's hand in marriage, you agree?
Sorry, lad, but you've come just a bit too late.
What? That's not fair. I mean, well, it's not fair.
Except I'm married. Hooray!
Drink so much, you know what they say. Drink as a knave, end up a slave.
You drunk and disorderly on a public street, you've had it.
Talk about a code of good conduct, meh.
Now, when you eat, never use all your fingers, but only the three fingers of the right hand.
When you eat and drink, you must do so silently.
After all, you're not so many puppies.
Anyway, be careful not to drop food on your clothes and stain them.
If you see or hear something distasteful, keep still about it and be discreet.
Do not leap upon and grab women as if an animal at feeding time.
In your attire, be neither too precise nor outlandish.
Above all, never wear dirty or torn clothing.
Now I must leave you, my children.
Other duties call me.
I'm truly sorry, for I like you all.
Any questions you want to ask?
Sir, the other day I was at the great feast in the temple.
I'm ashamed, but there was blood everywhere there.
I didn't like seeing it.
Tell me, wise master, do the gods always thirst for the blood of men?
I understand how you must have felt, but not all gods are like that.
In the past, we had a god who was fair and good,
Quetzalcoatl, the plumed serpent god.
He was the enemy of all violence.
In sacrifices, he took only the blood of serpents and birds, hence his name.
But Tezcatlipoca, who is a wicked god, a magician, jealous of his goodness,
bewitched him and chased him away.
And our divine Quetzalcoatl went to exile across the water of the eastern seas.
But one day soon, he will return. Believe it, all the oracles tell us this.
And 30 years later, from across that eastern sea,
Taken for the god Quetzalcoatl came Cortes, the conquistador.
And it was the end of the Aztec dynasty, cities, palaces, pyramids.
All this splendor was to disappear, swept away by a horrible nightmare.